- All right, let's wrap up this hour with
something cool I found on social media.
This is, "What I'm Liking"
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
It's impressive to see
even one person leaping
out of a perfectly good airplane.
But check out this view.
Yep, that's 80 women who came together
for a Guinness World record breaking
vertical skydive over the Arizona desert
and it was all for a purpose.
We have the co-captain
and one of the sky divers
of Project 19 on the line to explain.
Let's say hi to Amy watching
on Arizona's family.
What's up Amy? (audience applauding)
- Hi, Kelly. Thank you for having me.
- Oh my God, absolutely.
So before we talk about the why,
explain to me the how, 80
women did that at once.
- The how.
So there were about 120 women,
some of the best sky divers
from all over the world.
There were 22 countries represented.
And at first we trained in small groups
all over the world.
And then we came together
in one big group.
- [Kelly] Look at that, oh my gosh.
Well, this jump like many with
Project 19 had a purpose, right?
- Yes, this jump was so special
because it was inspired
by the women of the suffrage movement.
In 1920, women got the right
to vote in the United States
and as professional female skydivers
we wanted to do something bold and brave
like these women and to honor these women.
So we kind of came up with
this idea and implemented it
to do this record in honor of them.
And, yeah, we'd been working on it
for a really long time
and just so excited.
Women in skydiving only represent
14% of all of active skydivers
in the United States.
So we really wanted to change that.
We're on a mission to change that.
And we actually have
another record planned
in about a year from now.
We're gonna do another world record
but it's gonna be both men
and women working together.
But, the fun thing is that it's gonna be
only women in the leadership role.
- Oh, wow.
It's so amazing what y'all
create (audience applauding)
like the art in the sky.
It looks like Tony's
Stark has just released
all his things at once. It's incredible.
Thank you so much, Amy.
I'm liking your post right now.
You are one brave woman.
(bell dinging and audience clapping)
and that's not all.
- [Amy] Thank you, Kelly.
- That's not all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pin, makers of G2,
the go-to pin of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to honor truly unstoppable people
apparently just like
you and your colleagues
so they're gonna be writing you a check
to the Women's Skydiving
Network for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience applauding)
- Oh, Kelly, thank you so much.
Thank you for all the good work you do.
- Oh, absolutely.
Have a great day, Amy
and thank you so much
to all our guests today,
Vin Diesel, Quentin Plair, and Noah.
Y'all have a great night.
And if it's not, try and change it.